turkey appears to be heading for its
first presidential election runoff with
counting from Sunday's vote in its final
stages president receipt remains short
of the 50 needed to win outright he says
he'll respect any decision to hold a
second round Victoria gatenby reports
[Music]
president
addressed supporters outside the
headquarters of the justice and
development party in Ankara it was his
first appearance since the polls closed
he told them he's ready for a runoff if
the election goes to a second round
we have seen that the margin with the
closest opponent is more than 2 million
votes and with the final result we will
see a wider margin we don't know if we
will have a runoff but if this is the
result of the first round the results of
the runoff will be the same if our
nation has decided to go to a second
round we will respect that decision
his main Challenger Kamal kilichdarolu
leads a six-party opposition Alliance
that's determined to unseat erdogan he
urged supporters to be patient
despite his smear campaign against us
erdogan hasn't gotten the result he
wanted we have to wait for the final
results if the first round wasn't enough
to receive the Mandate we are going to
get it in the runoff election
election officials have been counting
the votes throughout the night a third
presidential candidate sin in Owen has
done better than expected analysts say
he has the potential to be king maker
one is an anti-immigrant anti-uh Refugee
candidate and I think it's basically a a
new Epoch in Turkish politics because
both sides will Court him to get his
votes and they will have to do at least
something to satisfy his base and his
message
so far Owen is refusing to back either
erdogan or kilichterolu music
there will be another difficult 15 days
ahead of us and during this time if the
elections are completed with the current
results and go to the second round we
will do our best to make this process a
good one for our nation and our country
at this time we are not saying that we
will support one party or the other
erdogan has led turkey for two decades
overseeing growth in trade and foreign
investment as well as ambitious
infrastructure development projects but
more recently he's been criticized for
high inflation and the Turkish lira's
devaluation to the U.S dollar
[Applause]
kilichterolu says he wants to reform the
system of governance and return power to
Parliament a runoff vote will almost
certainly be needed to decide turkey is
future Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
we're going to go live to Sami zedan
who's in Istanbul as part of our special
coverage of the elections
thanks so much yes let's bring you up to
speed with where things stand after a
really intense night of vote counting
well here we are President
urduan leads the first round of voting
according to the unofficial results that
have been put out so far
no candidate has an outright majority
the ruling Coalition is also leading in
parliamentary elections and nationalists
have done better than expected we've got
our correspondence right across turkia
following this story for us we have
zainer joining us from Ghazi and tap
looking at how the Heartland has voted
cinemasaldo is watching things from
Istanbul
opposition party headquarters in Ankara
but first we start with our soul Sardar
he's also in Ankara at the ruling art
parties headquarters and Resort even
though Thai bordwan did not get an
overall majority didn't get more than 50
but they're seeing this as a victory
right
that's correct Sammy because just before
the elections we have seen that the
polls are showing a solid lead of the
opposition leader Kamal however the
picture that we have now doesn't
actually confirm that so as of now more
than 99 percent of the wars are counted
and erdogan has already secured more
than 49 persons of the world so that is
regardless quite success so yesterday
right on the balcony of this building
behind me which is aquati's headquarter
at night late in the night has delivered
a speech to his supporters and he said
that as of now the unofficial results
are not announced yet however he is
going to respect the nation's will but
he also very much strongly signaled that
it's going to be the second round and
his speech mostly was regarded as a
campaign speech so we can say that he
already has started his campaign for the
second around so his messages were
around the terrorism and the cooperation
of the opposition or indirect
cooperation of the opposition with the
terror group such as pkk which is not
the terrorist of turkey and and European
union and the USA and says that we
haven't been in collaboration with them
he has promised a more powerful turkey
and he said that this great March toward
the investment is not going to stop so
all of these messages were regarded as a
as a as a campaign as he started his
campaign for the second round and we can
see that by sending out these messages
he was building up on the nationalists
and conservatives base in Turkey because
this is the results of the the latest
election have shown us that nationalism
is on Rise and conservatism in this
country is still having the biggest bulk
of the of the awards here and also the
other messages that he sends out Unity
stability and continuity so that's also
some
during all of his election campaign was
building up on he was saying that our
party or the People's Alliance which
he's leading is is only the guarantor of
the stability in the country the unity
in the country and the continuity in the
country on the other hand he was
accusing the opposition of being
fragmented and fragile and he was
quoting on Waters not to jeopardize his
Unity stability and continuity in Turkey
so in that sense we can say that he has
already started this campaign
foreign
the focus now is on the second round of
voting talk us through the strategy of
the arc party to try and clinch a bigger
majority in the SEC or a bigger win in
the second round
well Sammy the picture as of now is is
quite clear so erdogan is regarded as a
winner after 21 year in power he still
was able to get almost 50 percent of the
awards in this in this country so the
nationalism and conservatism are on rise
or they are stable in this country on
the other hand we see that the the the
opposition is quite fragile and they
couldn't get what they wanted some of
the three itself two parties displayed
from our party the the good party and
the democracy and progress party led by
the Ahmed Auto Land Alibaba and also the
Felicity party which is regarded as the
islamist party in Turkey they have
joined CHP but as when we look at the
results we see that they had very little
contribution to the main opposition
important that has also been heavily
criticized on the other hand as I said
nationalism don't rise the biggest
surprise was
Alliance so no one was expecting him to
get more than five percent and also we
see that nationalist MHP parties secured
more than 10 nationalist good party
secured around 10 percent so this is
this is giving us a picture however here
one of the other surprises is the new
welfare party led by fatiharback and the
son of a former conservative prime
minister in turkey and he got almost
three percent of the war so and he's in
Alliance with erdogan so that was also
another surprise of this but when it
comes to the losing sides the leader of
the opposition is now heavily being
criticized by many of his supporters
that the strategy was wrong and also on
the other hand we see that while the
People's Alliance is sending out the
message of the unity now we probably are
going to see the internal files within
the opposition and these next two weeks
toward the second run are going to be
quite tense and tired Sammy
Russell you mentioned so we're going to
thank you very much for the reporting
from the headquarters of the art party
let's take this now to the headquarters
of kamalu's uh pay or republican
People's Party we've got Hashem standing
by live for us there and Hashim this
result of the first round means an
uphill challenge for Kamal
kalashtarollu's opposition Coalition do
they think they can turn this around in
a second round
it is an Uncharted Territory for them
Sammy for the simple reason is that when
the crafted their own election campaign
for the first round they wanted to win
the election in the first round for the
simple reason they built their campaign
on the assumption that if in the areas
which were hit by the earthquakes
the resentment and The Descent grows
they will tap into that resentment and
they will get significant portion of the
votes from those areas and that will be
enough for them to boost their chances
other parliamentary elections and then
to move forward two they thought that
there is a trend in the country that
would pave the way for more young voters
with no political affiliations young
people pretty much concerned more about
the need to modernize the country to
think more about economy what they saw
yesterday was surprising to them
particularly the earthquake hit areas
voting for erdoran and also the rise of
nationalism so to starting from tomorrow
when they start thinking about their
campaign for the runoff it is going to
be an uphill climb for them
I'm going to be an uphill is this also
becoming something of a threat to the
unity of the Coalition Hashem
foreign
candidate along with the other key
members of the opposition Coalition came
on the stage and they said we need to
stand united we are definitely going to
win the election because there is
mounting aspiration among the Turkish
people for the need to bring about
genuine democracy and reform the economy
it was for a particular reason because
he does understand that they will have
to hold together the opposition for the
runoff this is an opposition that has
been divided because of huge differences
over a wide range of political and
economic issues now when they move
forward they are going to Grapple with a
key issue here are there going to be
able to convince to join them has it
stands for the for the right with the
ultra nationalist agenda and not
everybody on this Coalition is is on the
same page with him so convincing him to
join without further upsetting the other
members of the opposition is going to be
extremely delicate number two they will
have to look at the map analyze the data
see where where they have failed where
they have made some gains and tried to
reinvent themselves in two weeks to be
able to win the election but they do
understand it is going to be extremely
difficult in fact in a way or another
they do understand they might need a
miracle to win the runoff
reporting to us there from Ankara let's
move this now from the political Capital
to the commercial and cultural Beating
Heart of turkia we've got synonym
crossover standing by for us live in
Istanbul and so then we know before this
election there was a vicious battle
going on for the big cities the ark
party trying to redeem itself of the
loss of some of these big cities during
the mayoral last mayoral elections where
did the big cities go so far in this
first round
well some yes we have been saying that
especially for Istanbul whoever wins
Istanbul would win turkey this is a
political understanding at tradition uh
among Turkish politicians this is what
they believe and we know that both the
opposition and the president's side have
been a fighting strong to get Istanbul
well in the parliament there are 600
seats and when I look at the current
results our party is the leading party
CHP is the second biggest party in the
parliament Pro Kurdish party with the
under the new umbrella name Greenleaf
party is the third and the Nationalist
party MHP is the fourth when you look at
Istanbul uh Sami is some in Istanbul
right now the ruling act party has the
biggest majority in the parliament with
40 seats then come CHP with 31 seats and
when you look at Ankara the Turkish
Capital again AG party is leading with
15 seats CHP follows that with 13 and
Izmir Izmir is the castle of the Turkish
secularist is the uh is a power base of
the Republican opposition party CHP
where they have 14 seats in the
Parliament and the ruling out party
eight seats of course this shows us that
especially Istanbul and Ankara the
ruling act part is still leading but in
Turkey the coastal cities are usually
the secularist ones mean supporting the
CHP the main opposition party or the
good party the secular nationalist party
and offshoot from the MHP but what is
more interesting is the Southeastern and
Eastern cities the Kurdish dominated
cities we see that the the green left
part Pro Kurdish party has literally
swept swept off these cities for
instance in hakkyari there are three MPS
all of them are pro Kurdish party again
not one of the biggest largest cities of
the region the broker this party is
leading this is a message of course for
president zardon and
who are going to renew their campaigning
and increase their hand in the
negotiating table to win those cities to
get over this neck and neck competition
Sami
thanks so much synonym crossover there
from Istanbul let's take this now to
gazi and tap one of those Heartland
areas of turkia where we've got
standing my life for us and one of the
big headlines from the the east of the
country when it comes to the Kurdish
vote it seems the head AP vote went more
to the opposition right
well yes but at the same time the main
Kurdish political force the hdp they
held a press conference a few hours ago
and they admitted defeat and in fact
Kurdish voters are very much
disappointed the Kurds or the hdp
entered this presidential race they
entered into a political Gambit they
decided to join the opposition Alliance
they thought that this is the best way
forward to unseat the president they
have fallen out with the ACT party in
recent years for them the priority is to
remove him from Power that's what we
felt after talking to you know officials
in that area and the people what
happened they lost seats in Parliament
they had 67 MPS in Parliament now 62 and
they lost it to their allies the CHP
which is also an unlikely partner
because before the ACT party came to
power 20 years ago it was chp-led
governments and they denied the Kurds
their rights so the Kurds feel that in
one way or another they have been used
by the different political parties so
there's a lot of disappointment there
they thought that this would be over in
the first round that if they don't feel
their own candidate like they did back
in 2018 that this would be over the
opposition would win and we've been
speaking to officials there and they say
A New Beginning will start a new era of
relations you know but that did not
happen so some are even questioning did
they make the right move if they entered
the race alone and maybe Garner 10 of
the vote then they could have a strong
hand on the negotiating table
all right let's uh now start analyzing
this and bring in our guests we have
joining us Ali chokriolo our analyst
political analyst so good for you to be
with us Ali let's start with taking a
step back and looking at the big picture
what went better for odewan than many
were expecting what went worse for the
opposition than many were hoping well
erdogan maintained its basis of support
in in the heartland of Anatolia in
Turkey
uh although he lost some support in the
Southeast he still maintained the
central Anatolian provinces and I think
he also maintained some credible level
of support in the big cities as well
does he now enter the second round with
momentum he's got more than his
challenge in the presidential election
he's got more in the parliament he does
have the momentum behind him he was very
successful also in the earthquake hit
region so that's one thing that was a
bit of a surprise
well but some people find it surprising
I also expected that you know there will
be some opposition support in the
Southeast in these earthquake regions
but he he apparently delivered what they
expected of him and promises that he
will deliver even better in the
aftermath of the election for the
opposition what was what went wrong is
they couldn't actually get any support
from the heart of the the heart rate the
heartland of turkey turkey and also some
of the alliance members could not
actually maintain their level of support
especially the nationalists the
Nationalist action party was very
successful I think in maintaining 10 to
11 percent of the the vote whereas
e-party a major partner in the
opposition Alliance was not able to
raise this level of support in any
significant way so those are the
nationalists in the opposition Alliance
so you look at other nationalists such
as what happened with sinan yes
some of them did better than expected
right much better it looks like the
fourth candidate resigning actually did
not help the opposition Alliance but
rather helped the nationalists or on a
campaign which perhaps is not surprising
but one would have hoped that you know
that support went more heavily to the
opposition because they have actually
are not voting for erdogan but voting
for a loser in a sense because Iran has
no chance of remaining to the second
round so we'll see what happens in the
next round the bottom line is this is a
nation that so far is leaning more
towards continuity than change that's
for sure but there is always some change
in the continuity as well why because
erdogan's Economic Policy needs some
changes some adjustments he might not be
able to exists those pressures from the
markets any longer after the election
and also there are political reforms
that might be brought to the agenda by
the new partners in the alliance Ali
always good talking to you we're going
to continue throughout the day thanks so
much for coming in right now we're going
to bring in another analyst in a moment
but while we're doing that let me just
bring you up to speed very quickly we've
had the first round of elections
99.4 of that vote has been counted and
it shows that president is doing better
than his main challenger no candidate as
I've been saying has won the election
outright but president has got it's been
placed at 49 his Challenger 49.42 his
challenge at Kamal kalashdarolu at 44 so
quite a big gap between the two
parliamentary election results again the
ruling Coalition with 49 which
translates into a majority of seats into
Parliament so far versus what the
opposition have which is just over a 34
or five percent of the vote so far all
right let's bring in now our next guest
we've got uh good to have Khan once
again akbash with us thank you so much
for coming in thanks for having a little
warmer now than it was last night and
it's not raining so that's good can we
break down Ali some of the the segments
of the vote that people were making a
lot of and let me start by asking you
what happened to the youth vote
great question
um it appears that given the third
candidate Cena no one's performance
they seem to either have not gone to the
polls or they seem to have voted for
change I.E or in terms of protesting
either candidate because uh Generation Z
have been expecting for Change and it's
interesting even they were polarized
among themselves and half of them they
had nothing to do with the politics but
the other half were like either
supporting nationalism and and turkey
sort of getting Bolder in the uh sort of
global Arena but it looks like
um neither one of them really voted for
either kalistarolu or erdogan what
happened to the Kurdish vote did they
put themselves in a box now by backing
or at least the hdp component of it the
opposition which is struggling now there
are many lessons to be taken after the
selection for the opposition parties but
if I look at the performance of the
Coalition partners and I wouldn't put
Kurdish as a part of the uh official
Coalition but still they performed uh in
line with the historical votes that they
secured and um but they are actually
themselves they do not consider
themselves successful based on their
sort of uh press releases so um I I
think that they were hoping to do far
better than they have done but
historically speaking this is as far as
they've gone and they've done this uh
against a a propaganda machine that
delivered really uh putting them uh
quote in bed with pkk so uh they didn't
do uh you know either way too too bad or
too great okay if we can call it the
earthquake vote did it go stronger to
erdogan and the arc party than some
people were predicting uh let me give
you an example these earthquakes
happened in marash and erdogan ended up
receiving his historically highest vote
in marash so for example adiaman he also
emerged with over 70 percent of the
electorate so
again even for those earthquake regions
um part of the issue I believe they
voted for uh you know the person the
leader that they know who placed them to
rebuild their lives in less than a year
and he even delivered in record time uh
some of the new houses built so um but
the other issue which you will see in
the second round I believe about half of
the electorate had to migrate to the
west and I'm not sure if they were able
to vote in the election so we will see
the impact of that other half of the
waters in the second round why will we
see it more in the second round do you
think there'll be more energized now uh
well in the second round I don't believe
overall there will be a higher turnout
than this historically High 88 percent
but I think it's going to go down to a
sort of really demoralized opposition
trying to mobilize their voters back to
the polls and I'm not sure if they will
have a clear message because turkey
voted for change in my mind and they
also voted for more nationalism and and
for more religious conservatism so I
think that there were messages to both
the ruling Alliance because if I look at
the numbers uh for example AKP lost some
more vis-a-vis 2018 but this showed the
political Genius of President erdogan
because his ruling Alliance did far
better than the opposition's alliance
said cautious support cautious support
for erdogan is that how we're putting it
um
another one is cool ahead I think he's
got the psychological advantage he's
closer to wind I think he needs about
350 000 votes as opposed to almost 3
million for the opposition so I think
he's very close to winner and he's going
to continue his his messages that seems
to have resonated and by the way all the
posters and pundits have really missed
uh the undercurrent uh the pro ruling
party under current which kind of
vindicates us that we were very cautious
and Al Jazeera with those polls everyone
had their polls saying different
absolutely anyway thank you so much for
talking to us thank you I know we're
going to talk more but for now here is
where we are we're looking ahead of
course now to a second round we'll be
here monitoring it for you for now I'm
going to hand you back to rob in Doha
too much we're going to be checking in
with you over the next few hours but for
now Sami zedan thank you